GOP Senator marubio sits on the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee and joins us
now Senator it's still coming they're
laughing at us essentially this guy's
making money off this Caravan and he's
saying what is wrong with America how
frustrating it is for you well it's very
frustrating because in fact our
intelligence agencies our government
does know that there are governments in
the region that are actively pushing
people in this direction for example
Nicaragua is monetizing it right
Nicaragua says you can travel you can
fly into Nicaragua without a Visa and so
people fly in from Cuba up until the
other day from Haiti from other places
and then you know they're facilitating
the route we know that the leftist
president of Colombia is actively
pushing Venezuelan migrants to leave
Colombia facilitating that pushing them
towards the United States so we know
that governments up and down the region
are doing that we know for a fact that
there are trafficking networks with
links to terrorism that are in the
business of moving and trafficking
people for money it's how they raise
money for terrorism but of course it's
logical to conclude that if they use
that if that's their business to make
money if they're a ren car agency and
you rent money to make you rent cars to
make money why wouldn't you rent a car
or give a car for free to a terrorist
since you're a terrorist organization
they're in that business it would easily
translate to them helping terrorists get
into the country as well it is a
Calamity they are turning America into a
refugee camp and it has to stop this is
not Migra this is a mass migration event
bordering on an invasion area event and
they're allowing it Biden is encouraging
and he's allowing it and now he wants
billions of dollars more to make the
process move even faster he's got his
mayor leaving left out to dry because
cities are outraged they don't have the
money for these people I mean Senator en
last time you've been to New York but
they're now handing people tents and
tell them they head to the park the
hotels are all filled with illegals
prostitution is overwhelming Queens with
these illegals because they have nothing
to do they think the process would be
getting them jobs only 1% of the illegal
immigrants showed up for a job interview
so they don't want to work this is a
self-inflicted devastating wound
to
America understand that no country in
the world would tolerate this none so
right now in the Middle East in the
middle of a war Egypt has said we stand
with the Palestinian people but not a
single one of them is coming into where
not a single Refugee is going to live in
the in the in the um uh in the Sinai so
they have sent military tanks they've
sent Weaponry to block Palestinian
refugees from entering the Sinai okay
and and and Jordan has said the same
thing they're not allowing refugees no
country in the world allows Mass
migration
except for Western countries like some
in Europe that now regret it and
increasingly the United States we are
talking this is not an immigration issue
this is a mass migration it is chaos it
is uncontrolled and of course they're
winding up in cities they have to live
somewhere and and I I made the point the
other night okay last year I'm just
using one number 900,000 people uh uh
confronted at the border released to the
United States if just one/ tenth of 1%
of those people are terrorists that's
900 terrorists you only need a few
terrorists to do a lot of damage imagine
900 of them and that's just in one year
and the OB and and the Biden
Administration is not just allowing this
they they are encouraging it through
their behavior and the reason why they
don't stand up to it is cuz if they do
they have the left radical wing of their
party that will Rebel and Revolt people
that believe that anyone who wants to
come here should be allowed to come here
no matter how they come here and be
allowed to stay forever and it is a
radical view but it is Tak it it is
basically dictating their policy well
good uh they've alienated a lot of
people it's going to make it easy for
Republicans to win elections I'm Steve
duy I'm kill me and I'm Angley airheart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis